hallo ihr lieben ihr wisst ja
mittlerweile dass ich käsekuchen über
alles liebe und dann gibt es ja so viele
verschiedene varianten und heute zeige
ich euch eine richtig gut angepasste zur
jahreszeit wir machen nämlich ein
spekulatius cheesecake und das gute ist
überhaupt keine maschine nur zutaten die
hier im supermarkt findet also nix
exotisch ist und das ganze geht auch
superschnell jetzt zeige ich aber
zuallererst mal die zutaten für den
boden und für den käsekuchen und das
topping zeige ich euch dann nachher
der boden besteht aus spekulatius keksen
und geschmolzener butter und der
cheesecake besteht aus dem magerquark
außerdem zucker eiern weichweizen gries
geschmolzene butter eine bio zitrone
backpulver und vanillezucker die
spekulatius kekse müssen zuallererst
verprügelt werden ich hab euch ja
versprochen in diesem video keine
maschinen zu benutzen ich hab da drüben
auch mein blender und damit mache ich
das normalerweise aber einige haben mich
gefragt kannst du vielleicht mal ein
rezept machen komplett ohne maschinen
und das halte ich heute ein
und jetzt gebe ich einfach die
spekulations kekse in meinen
gefrierbeutel und haut dann mit dem
nudelholz drauf und holte ein bisschen
drüber dass sie schön klein werden
[Musik]
so die kekse sind schön klein und jetzt
gehen wir noch unsere geschmolzene
butter mit dazu und dann ganz einfach
verrühren und somit uns unser boden auch
schon fertig und das riecht schon
richtig lecker leute sagt euch und jetzt
holt unsere springt vor michael 26 cm
springt ihr könnt auch nur 24 oder 28er
nehmen und ich habe da jetzt kein
backpapier darunter gegeben wenn ich
finde dass der boden eigentlich ganz
leicht da rauskommt jetzt gehen wir den
komplett rein und drücken schön fest an
[Musik]
und am besten funktioniert das mit
seinem glas wo ihr unten so ein richtig
geraten abschluss haben könnte dass
nämlich richtig schön fest andrücken
[Musik]
mein spekulatius boden habe ich jetzt
bis zur weiterverarbeitung in den
kühlschrank gegeben es dauert jetzt auch
nicht lange ungefähr fünf minuten wenn
überhaupt wir geben jetzt alle zutaten
in eine große schüssel die stadt jetzt
mit dem magerquark gibt da erst mal
butter und eier hinein und zuckermann
ferro ich das erstmal
[Musik]
und anstelle des vanillezucker könnt ihr
jetzt auch vanille extrakt oder zimt
neben sind wir auch ganz gut passen
aber ich bleibe jetzt heute bei vanille
und gleich kommen noch die abgeriebene
zitronenschale mit rein
falls ihr keine bio zitrone da habt dann
könnt ihr jetzt auch alternativ zum
beispiel ein spritzer zitronensaft
reingeben das funktioniert auch sehr gut
[Musik]
quark masse ist jetzt gut miteinander
verbunden und als nächstes gehe ich
backpulver und weichweizen drews mit
hinein und wer keinen weizen ist der
kann auch hartweizengrieß nehmen so ihr
lieben arbeitszeit bis jetzt war nur
zehn minuten als ihr seht dieses rezept
ist sehr schnell und unkompliziert jetzt
finde ich die käsekuchen masse auf den
boden und dann gebe ich das ganze in den
backofen
[Musik]
und so geben wir den kuchen in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 180 grad ober
unterhitze für circa 40 bis 45 minuten
anschließend las mir vollständig
auskühlen so ihr lieben nicht wundern
ist es jetzt der nächste tag und meinen
käsekuchen es schon vollständig
abgekühlt haben jetzt auf meine
tortenplatte gelegt und jetzt zeige ich
euch das 4 stopp hing und das schmeckt
total lecker aber wir haben hier
spekulatius gewürzt richtig richtig gut
zu den kirchen die kirchen habe ich hier
schon abtropfen lassen hier habe ich die
kirschen und den saft in meinem kopf
außerdem benötigen wir noch zucker und
stärke und die drei zutaten gebe ich
jetzt in den topf und rühre dass einmal
gut um
[Musik]
und sobald das ganz schön klümpchen frei
ist schalten wir den herd ein und kochen
das einmal auf
nach dem aufkochen liegt das sofort 1
durch mein schneebesen weg gebe die
kirchen rein und dann ruhig das mit
einem löffel richtig schön um wahr würde
den schneebesen benutzen wird dann
würden euch die kirchen kaputt gehen wo
als nächstes geben wir die heißen
kirschen auf den käsekuchen und
eigentlich ist die griechen dann schon
fertig ihr können den kuchen auf
genießen solange die kirschen noch heiß
sind aber ich habe gleich noch eine idee
ich werde gleich noch ein bisschen sahne
aufschlagen und dann zeige ich euch wie
ich das ganze dekoriert deshalb werde
ich hier auch ein bisschen abstand
laufen am rand so ungefähr 2 bis 3 cm
[Musik]
und das riecht schon so lecker der ganze
raum riecht nach spekulatius und das
werde ich jetzt erstmal abkühlen lassen
schlage mir inzwischen treibt kurz
darauf ganz einfach umgesetzt und dann
zeige ich euch die restliche deko nach
zehn minuten ist die obere schicht auch
schon richtig schön abgekühlt und dann
können wir mit der sahne ran
ihr könntet auch spekulationsgewinne
nochmal in die saane reingeben auch sehr
lecker und ich habe keine spritzmittel
mehr gehabt deshalb habe ich hier in
einem gefrierbeutel genommen sieht ein
bisschen lustig aus aber egal mache mich
unter so nicht ganz einfach auch
spritzen ich habe hier so eine schöne
rosenmüller daran gemacht eine große und
jetzt wird sich das einfach schön an den
rand
[Musik]
und jetzt ist der spekulatius kate
wirklich fertig ihr könnt ihn jetzt drei
tage waren genießen der hex im
kühlschrank super frisch und schmeckt
total lecker mich erinnerte sehr an
winter und weihnachten einfach diese
ganzen gewürze das passt super super gut
zusammen ihr könnt das ganze jetzt gerne
nachmachen die genauen mengenangaben
schreibe ich euch hier unten in die
infobox ansonsten hinterlassen wieder
gerne einen dollar nach oben abonniert
meinen kanal dann verpasst ihr auch
nichts mehr
es erwarten euch noch ganz ganz viele
leckere torten dieser art und nimmt
viele raffinierte sachen freue mich wenn
ihr damit im nächsten mal auch wieder
dabei zeit und schon gerne drüber auf
instagram da seid ihr immer top aktuell
informiert und könnte auch ganz oft
nicht abstimmen was ich hier auf dem
kanal abstimmen also bis zum nächsten
mal auf die disk imaging
[Musik]